[Music]
has to move fast
i don't like the position my queen is in
but i'm up a lot of material
[Music]
uh sure trade oh
what
[Music]
what is going on
didn't take my queen dude
oh no what are you doing
oh my god
[Music]
okay he got a piece it's fine um
we trade
[Music]
this is a very sad story for executives
oh
oh my god why am i trying to get all
this pie i swear i was just about to say
it and it happened so fast
oh my god
you see the miracle come back still mate
he was giving up his pieces on purpose
and he achieved the stalemate
i didn't think jack was going to play so
fast i was about to say now queen h3 is
mate but queen h7 and then
queen h3 was made queen 87 stalemate and
the latter happened oh my gosh
excuse me with five seconds left on the
clock manages to
get into a stalemate position and forced
to draw
i threw up my back if you wrote my back
[Music]
okay